hey guys it's beat peppers with candy
crush saga saga tips calm and had a lot
of questions about level 138 some
players are stuck in the group so I was
going to make a commentary video with
some tips so the you know we have a lot
of licorice coils here behind the honey
so the striped candies aren't super
useful so more what I'm trying to do is
try to make some raft you maybe even
maybe even try to like match them with
the way have a couple that are trapped
in the honey somebody trying to make two
and match them together maybe if I can
and just basically working down fish
aren't that great but they can be good
with them wraps also because they'll go
down and we just want to clear coils
like we're doing so that we can figure
out where the Bears are there's three of
them but they're small and they're not
always in the same place so so that's
pretty good when we got a lot of space
here now and we're going to want to make
matches they're going to take out coils
and make specials at the same time like
that one and we just like I said we want
to get rid of enough of them so that we
can use striped candies and things to
figure out where the Bears are so here I
think we can just go ahead and match the
orange so that showed us where to the
Bears are so I want to go ahead and get
these out of the way we can drop the
purple normally the Purple's with the
blue come out and get the first bear now
we can open up a little more space on I
think the spares vertical so it's gonna
yeah there's still going to be one more
there we got to get but there's a little
fish match so that's good and now you
have one more air and 11 moves and that
sounds like a lot but still have a long
way to go actually so like I said the
plan is you know basically just keep
making wraps and try to set them off
lower you know we have a red and green
one here but they're pretty high out so
I'm not really going to do much
a couple choices here they all involve
these blue pieces in the middle I think
the fish is probably best all right so
what I would like to do here is clear
out some of the space so I can fire this
yellow striped across to rescue the bear
but I got a couple piece of honey in
behind the honey I've got coil so
definitely want to thank these out the
only have five moves if we can get rid
of some of the coils then we will be
able to clear the bear out but we have a
couple choices here I can make the
strike imagine what the fish but that's
not super I could go anywhere you know
they don't go where the Bears are know
if it's a nice it's across the level so
here I like this let's make this and
hopefully that will show us where the
bear is and it did Wow nowhere to match
them but hey look we can make this
orange striped here I know it's showing
a wrap but we can make a strike instead
and then we can set it off on the last
move so this is going to do it so
nothing loser all notice yep and that's
that so for tips I mean that you know
the main thing is this is annoying board
definitely we need to plan things
through you're not going to get lucky
and just blow the whole board up because
the licorice coils are there so try to
be somewhat technical and break through
the honey quick get rid of coils and
then look for where the Bears are and
don't don't really waste your time
clearing off any other ice just go
straight for the Bears wherever they are
hope this helps please like the video
subscribe to our channel and check back
regularly so
because we'll be making more of these
type of videos leave a comment if you
have any questions talk to you soon